die tägliche packung lust und frust
sammeln diese archaische impuls des
menschen etwa bei panini bildern
es gibt ihn als trieb fieber wut oder
als leidenschaft die leiden schafft das
einkleben als festkleben an der hoffnung
gesuchte zu finden entweder weniger auch
er schließt gerne lippen
andreas sommer mitherausgeber einer
philosophie des sammelns
der münzensammler weiß allzu gut was
seinesgleichen antreibt den homo
kollektor dass sie also neues wort finde
und erkennen zweiten aspekt ist
selektivität die muss auswählen kann die
allesamt und im service konzentrieren
das ist in phase im leben genauso
wichtig wie rim sammler dritten das
praktisch ich muss mir keiner was auch
trainer selektivität bedeutet muss sein
es war das heißt andere hinter sich oder
das ist von mensch der aber genauso wie
versammlung
entscheidend waren sagen dass der
sammler kilometer in idealtypischer
menschen keine zu klein homo kollektor
zu sein
das objekt mark wertlos sein das tun ist
wertvoll denn das kind sammelt nicht
bloß gegenstände sondern erfahrungen
die umwelt wird greifbar und ermöglicht
besitz nach eigenem gutdünken
eine sammlung ist freilich kein
sammelsurium der homo kollektor kein
messi wie dieser bewahrt er zwar auf
läuft an
doch tut er dies überlegt der sammler
kreiert in dem er neu arrangiert und
schafft damit ordnung struktur
kurzum neues aus altem
das ist wichtiger aspekt so gern
unterschlagen wird beim sammler dass
nämlich das sammlers alternativen aktiv
dank im sommer sind eigentlich bloß
rezept eve dean eine sache wo irgend wie
groß sind die spiele kunstsammler was
aber künstlerisch sammlung sind aber
selber organismen kunstwerk aufs ganze
die sammlung ist noch mehr prestige
objekt ruhepol in unserer schnelllebigen
wegwerfgesellschaft oder trutzburg im
teils chaotischen alltag nur das ein und
alles sollte sie nicht sein sonst wird
ihr besitzer zum sonderling erst recht
bei vermeintlich im ramsch wie der
philosoph bestätigt dieser sammler von
erkenntnis gezogen
ideale ordnung eine künstliche paradies
sondern sammlermuseum versuch sozusagen
teil von der welt nämlich das was einmal
zusammen ist gegenstand reizt sie zeigen
machen also irgendwo zu finden und auf
schlaue art in die eigene kontrolle zu
bringen
sammler die heutigen jäger aus
leidenschaft eitelkeit oder zur wert
vermehrung und zwar mann wie frau fast
alle die es sich finanziell erlauben
können haben diesem tun schon gewöhnt
sagt die forschung
sammeln macht ja auch klug sammler das
leben das es immer mit unvollständigkeit
behaftet ist dass der unvollständigkeit
aber optisch wohl ganz großen ansporn
darstellt die unvollständigen wirklich
zusammen glücklich macht unvollständige
lebenslange beim glück gemacht
das gilt auch für diese bildchen jäger
streben nach perfektion erreichen
lücken beglücken
denken sie daran wenn sie sich das
nächste mal sammeln